all right
welcome to the game awards 2022. now
here's your host the creator of the game
awards Jess Keeling
[Applause]
hello everybody and welcome to the game
awards it feels so amazing to be back in
person with the fans and to have the
entire industry with us here tonight
I love it such great energy I want to
say hello to all the nominees uh Mr
Miyazaki great to have you here
nominated for Game of the Year tonight
which is great
Kratos himself Christopher Judge is in
the house
man engage incredible and immortality
welcome to the game awards
of course we have Phil Spencer from Xbox
with us welcome Phil
foreign
Bowser from Nintendo you saw him
accepting an award already in the
opening act and uh
lots more Awards to come
and of course last year's Game of the
Year winner Joseph Ferris is back
he's here look
who's here guys
can't take him anywhere I should have
booked Kermit all right well welcome to
all the nominees and to all of you
watching live around the world thank you
for being a part of this community
tonight we are going to honor the best
games of the year and show you what's
next with an absolutely
incredible World premiere lineup
including the first ever look at the
gameplay of Star Wars Jedi Survivor from
respawn
an update on Final Fantasy 16.
the first ever clip from the Super Mario
Brothers movie
and many many new game announcements and
surprises trust me we've got a lot of
things no leaks we're very excited about
what we're about to share with you guys
now though it's time for our first award
to present it I am so honored to welcome
one of the great actors of Our
Generation or any other he's a two-time
Tony winner a two-time Emmy winner and
an Academy Award winner please join me
in welcoming to the game awards Al
Pacino
foreign
it's really good to see you here
uh this is uh an experience for me
what I didn't expect but here I am
as usual doing my surprising thing to
myself
but uh anyway
uh I I I may come as uh it may come as a
shock to you
but uh I I I I'm it's hard for me to see
the teleprompter
but anyway
uh but uh in the in truth
I don't play a whole lot of video games
work
I do have however spent a lot of time
watching my kids play them
and I've continued to be thoroughly
impressed and uh
entertained by the uh unique and
immersive Ways video games
tell their stories
and especially
especially naturally
by the performance
who helped tell these stories
uh because as an actor I've learned that
whether you're on a stage or in front of
a camera
or inside an audio booth
always
fundamentally always we're the same
uh we we are all trying to tell a story
in our way
uh with our kind of Truth
and I am honored
to be here tonight
to celebrate the achievements
of these incredibly talented actors who
by breathing life into these stories
have helped elevate
the medium of video games to a new
height
and now
and not the nominees for the best
performance of the year
oh best performance
I have to find a way to fix it all and
the answer is
nice
and quiet go to hell and still I follow
that can happen do what's necessary I
don't find boys have much to say for
themselves
scare me I can't talk about it but you
don't believe in any of it who's keeping
you safe
[Applause]
best performance
I'm working out now this is heavy
finally I didn't work out today so I'm
doing you don't mind doing if I do a
little league
the best performance
winner
Christopher Judge
foreign
[Applause]
[ __ ]
okay
now I see why I couldn't get more than a
plus one
um
thank you to the game awards
um
first of all uh I have to thank my mama
um
who's
belief that I would amount to something
good would uh never waver even though it
looked like I'd never amount to anything
good
my brother
who's my hero
at 40.
change his life
went to medical school and is now Dr
Judge
[Applause]
my children
[Applause]
who I am forever
proud of
forever thankful of and still the best
role I've ever had is being your dad
Sony Santa Monica
Miss Yumi yang
it is an honor and a pleasure
to work for you and with you you are a
unicorn because you actually proved that
for the first time ever
the trickle-down Theory actually worked
Corey barlog thank you brother
thank you uh for
believing in me and thank you for having
me read for the role
um
I was the last actor in California to
read for it
um and Corey
said to me he didn't think I would do it
and uh if I had known it was a video
game back then I might not have
boy how things have changed
um
Matt
rich
[Applause]
Dory Bruno Erica B oh
everyone
who made that volume so special
and so sacred
uh everyone
at every level
be a designer be it whatever it was who
worked
under extraordinary conditions
to get this game out
hmm
[Applause]
Mr Eric Williams
uh I I think it's kind of common
knowledge that uh
we were honored to go to Tribeca after
2018.
and When Corey took me outside and said
he wouldn't be directing the next one I
literally did quit
quit
and he said no
I vouch for Eric
and I said
Eric Williams better be a beast
Eric Williams is a [ __ ] Beast
[Applause]
I relate
to Corey on
kind of a artistic level a
level of of that side of me
Eric Williams and I
are from such the same place two
different parts of the country
two different upbringings
but two from a very similar
emotional place
and
I'll never forget
I guess I can't say what it was but it
was something
that moved me
so deeply and
there's a there's a time frame that
cinematics have to fit into
hopefully not speeches
um
and I I couldn't reel it in
and Eric came over to me
and he just hugged me and just held me
as I was sovereign
and then he said words I will never
forget
okay big guy now give us one we can use
to
this amazing wonderful
group of actors
um
who
brought as much or more
than I did
every single day
I mean we were in there and
The Bravery of
this group of actors who share their
heartache their loves their lost loves
their loneliness
I am so grateful and thankful
that
I got to spend all those days in that
volume with you this is for all of us
Sonny
I wasn't lying I voted for you
your work was astounding
you're the future of this
just never
forget
the two things I hopefully gave you
hire me
don't be a douchebag
to every single person in this room no
matter what game it was you touched you
are heroes because you got so many
people in the world through a very
difficult dark time that's still not
over
[Applause]
games in the gaming community means so
much to this world it's so much
in the course of dreams and escapism and
and just
being better
um thank you thank you to the rest of
the nominees
have a great night
and I met Al Pacino
[Music]
[Applause]
great moment Chris judge I think he was
trying to give away a few extra steam
decks as well all right it's time to get
the announcements rolling here at the
game awards tonight many of the world's
top studios are here at the game awards
to give you a glimpse at the exciting
future of video games in 2023 and beyond
our first world premiere comes from a
small but highly acclaimed Studio that
needs no introduction at this point and
whose last game earned multiple Awards
here at TGA I'm very excited to share
the global announcement of their next
project here we go
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
good
not good enough
we can but learn and the greatest
teacher is out there now go
death to Christmas
[Music]
this is an opportunity for you to make a
better future for us all the least I can
do is light your way down
[Music]
about ready to give in no I was born
full of powers far beyond your
comprehension which
okay if I call you back like that
feel family awaits you
it is no mere Titan he is time itself
and time cannot be stopped
wait for me Father I'll be this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and trust me we are just getting started
Hades 2 is the next game and first ever
sequel now in development at supergiant
games like the original which was
revealed here at TGA in 2018 Hades 2 is
going to be developed in Early Access so
your feedback can help shape the game
and news on Early Access is coming in
2023
next I'm so excited about this one we're
taking a journey to an exciting New
World with a world premiere from a
studio led by someone with a legacy of
building incredible narrative driven
games and creating genre defining
experiences it's moments like this that
get me excited about the future of our
medium
[Applause]
is dying
and my only way out of here
with one of them
[Music]
thank you
people say half is coming
and you know what
they're right
[Music]
[Applause]
few surprises tonight that was a first
look at Judas coming from Ghost Story
games led by Ken Levine who has created
immersive gaming worlds like Rapture in
Colombia a few months ago I visited the
studio in Boston and played multiple
hours of this game and let me tell you
everything you saw there is an in-engine
ghost story games is also exploring
different approaches to narrative that
you will learn about in the future let
me just say I can't wait for them to
tell you more didn't that look fantastic
exciting stuff
all right well let's go to another brand
new game announcement for the fans here
at the game awards
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Forest
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm going to be awake I need to be
strong
I will give you the power to save your
mother
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Teresa and the lost demon
[Applause]
foreign
that's right falling on the heels of
Bayonetta three it won't be long until
you get to play this brand new
action-adventure game in the Bayonetta
series on March the 17th all right there
are lots more new game announcements and
awards to come but tonight you also have
a shot at some cool free stuff just for
watching the game awards on Steam valve
is giving away a steam deck every minute
to a viewer of the show so I was gonna
start talking slowly but I probably
should start talking a little quicker
after Chris's speech but I'm so glad
that he won that award uh but seriously
steam deck is incredible and you can
watch on steam.tv we also have twitch
viewer rewards Watch 60 Minutes of the
show tonight on our twitch Channel and
you'll get the limited edition Jeff
Keeley Among Us masks yes it's back an
awesome Kate Diaz for Gears of War
costume in Fall Guys and a full free
game Rogue Legacy on the epic game store
and more we'll be right back with a
spectacular performance from Hozier and
the game awards Orchestra more Awards
announcements and yes Animal from The
Muppets we'll be back
people on the server are my family I
remember being at my lowest point the
members of This Server were here for me
seeing everyone in the Discord this
world of passion and grief but in a
positive life I have been through so
much with these people this really made
me believe that video games can help
people heal
[Music]
we love how you have fun
from serving up Sports at home to
competing and cooperating in fresh ways
catching new adventures in vast worlds
so what's next more fun
from adorable Adventures
to blasts from the past
[Music]
much much more
[Music]
when it comes to having fun the sky's
the limit
[Music]
see where the fun takes you in 2023
[Music]
one of my favorite parts of this show is
bringing video game music to life on
stage now to perform blood upon the snow
from tonight's most nominated game God
of War Ragnarok please welcome multiple
Platinum grammy-nominated Hozier feature
featuring bear Mccreary and the game
awards Orchestra conducted by Lauren
Bell
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the wolf that seeks always its own kind
[Music]
s
of winter homes
[Music]
[Applause]
froze the winter sun praise
[Music]
[Music]
oh
it ceases never to hunger
all things Nature's
gift she takes all things back from the
living
I've walked the Earth in the air so few
years
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
wow what an incredible performance the
game awards Orchestra I'm grateful to
have them back again and it's sincerely
a joy to hear the music from games we
love come to life on this stage uh it's
amazing what that Orchard puts together
in just a few weeks of rehearsal they'll
be back later in the show to pay tribute
to our game of the year nominees
this year a record-setting number of you
voted 55 million for the game awards on
our website on Billy Billy in China and
on our Discord server you can head over
to discord.gg the game awards tonight to
join in the discussion about the show
right now to present our next award from
the new film Glass Onion and knives out
mystery premiering December 23rd on
Netflix please welcome Jessica hennick
foreign
anyone
but someone in this room
is a murderer
just kidding we're just joking around
but also statistically speaking someone
in this theater probably is a murderer
I'm sorry let's not think about that
anyway I don't want to spoil our film
but I can tell you that there is a very
popular video game featured in it and
now to give you some more clues please
welcome writer director Ryan Johnson and
the star of Glass Onion Daniel Craig
thank you Jessica hedgewick hello game
awards uh we are so excited for you to
see our new film uh we have a special
scene in it for fans of a certain game
so we wanted to bring a little something
to that game
[Music]
it's very very nice yeah and now
Best debut Indy we're Sinners plucked
from hell to do God's dirty work I'm
finding it hard to believe we're in
heaven
[Music]
[Applause]
and the game Award for Best debut Indie
goes to
stray
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you thank you so much it's an
incredible Honor on behalf of the whole
team in Montpellier is probably watching
right now hi guys
um I want to thank everyone that was
involved in making this uh this game
it's really a work of love and passion
and all the talented members of our team
put everything they have to make this
game real thanks to everyone who has
helped us along the way our friends
families Partners companions dogs cats
obviously pretty important
um and I'm pretty interactive you guys
are amazing you make dreams happen thank
you so much you've been with us the
whole way through thank you thank you so
much
um and yeah thank you to the players we
put such a big part of our Lives making
this game so seeing people enjoy it and
react to it is the best feeling in the
world so thank you merci Merced
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations Trey and now an
exclusive first look at the gameplay
from lightfall Destiny 2's next chapter
launching in February join your fellow
Guardians to master the cosmic powers of
the universe and cancel the apocalypse
when we think about controlling
something powerful it's easy to assume
it takes strength but what I've learned
through loss we can overcome the
impossible
[Music]
all right
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
all right flash is clear
eyes on him people
somebody find the back entrance
oh crap
this door will not hold we must
barricade it
say this
I spent a lot of time dreaming up how I
was gonna kill you with
your mind now and you're in for a world
one
oh
[ __ ]
oh oh hi guys oh we were just having a
life
you hear that
please help me
hey Bruce
still using Shadows to scare the crap
out us criminals huh
don't sweat it Batman doesn't kill
people
are you okay
[Music]
I am Vengeance I am the night
I am Batman
[Applause]
after 30 years is the iconic voice of
Batman and the Arkham video games Batman
the Animated Series and countless other
DC projects actor Kevin Conroy sadly
passed away last month at the age of 66.
he was such an iconic voice he was so
amazing in the Arkham games and I know
we're all going to miss him dearly well
tonight we can share that he will return
to rocksteady's Arkham verse one final
time to play Batman in Suicide Squad
kill the Justice League when the game
releases on May 26th of next year
we're gonna miss Chicago
now as we think about the next phase of
our industry it's important to recognize
those who represent the bright bold and
inclusive future of gaming that's why we
have our game awards future class
presented by Old Spice and tonight over
75 members of the class from the past
two years are here in the audience hello
guys
and this week we inducted the 2022 class
of 50 50 new members you can read about
them at tgafutureclass.com and right now
meet one of this year's new members a
chemist turned Game Dev at intersloth
who also happens to be a street dancer
I am Mick mignier I'm the lead back-end
programmer on Among Us and I'm a street
dancer named Dr robotics I was looking
at the movement of NPCs and video games
and realized that we as animation
dancers have the unique ability to show
the body control the robotics we have
the ability to bend time and reality
it's really exciting I think there's a
lot of potential to bridge these two
different art forms
all right
from the studio we spent two years
recreating their own game recreate
Studio presents
prepare your friends for a cute and
relaxing Animal Crossing like experience
and then brutally destroy them all devs
claim this game will improve your
relationship with friends oh brother
help me yeah sure the party animals an
epic battle of the most epic animal
characters starring Royal Corgi orange
cat Canada Goose [ __ ] a regular duck
that looks like absolutely no one all of
these animals have very fancy outfits an
actual Royal Corgi an actual orange cat
an actual Canada Goose an actual this is
Sparta
let's interview the game producer what
inspired you want to make so many
outfits for these cute animals
join the epic battle taking place in
some of the most epic places
don't try these in the human world
a submarine destroying the world
a freezing cold fighter jet
a station where Keanu Reeves fought a
dude wearing a suit
up in black hole
football
Trey Boucher
exploding basketball
while the game offers various modes to
encourage different styles of gameplay
but we all know that the only thing
that's truly interesting is to watch
your friends lose their [ __ ]
oh I forgot there are lots of weapons
all very realistic
John Wick really needs to learn how to
use this
and the final and biggest feature of the
game butt scratching
party animals play with your friends on
Steam and Xbox coming 2023
Trump
no way
PlayStation
that's right the last of us is
officially coming to PC on March 3rd and
later in the show the cast of The Last
of Us show from HBO will be with us to
present an award but now to present best
adaptation please welcome the host of
TGA opening act Sydney Goodman
tonight we're presenting a brand new
Award for best adaptation this award
celebrates when beloved characters and
stories from gaming are lovingly
transported to films and television here
are the nominees
best adaptation
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Sonic Meet Knuckles
Return to Sender oh come on what the
hell are you doing
[Music]
end the game Award for best adaptation
goes to
Arcane League of Legends
wow I mean it's an incredible honor to
you know be awarded by the video game
Community you know we're all we're
Gamers at heart uh who built this and uh
it's been a long long journey getting
here uh definitely like to thank uh
fortish you know his amazing animation
you see in every frame of the show uh
Netflix has been a wonderful partner of
course
of course Riot you know for believing in
us to Mark Sean and Brandon this is our
uh it's just been it's been an
incredible ride and I've
can't thank you enough so once again
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
speaking of adaptations later we'll have
the first clip from the new Super Mario
Brothers animated movie can't wait to
have that Keegan Michael Keel be with us
all right now back to the games coming
later in the show we'll have an update
on Final Fantasy 16. a new look at
cyberpunk's Phantom Liberty expansion
and the first game play raw gameplay
footage of Tekken eight there's lots
more game awards to come and that means
lots more steam decks to give away but
now it's time for the world premiere of
a long-awaited game
[Music]
[Music]
view order is gone
I was betrayed by the one I trusted most
I will not be imprisoned again
thank you
[Music]
I hear you've been busy making yourself
the Empire's Most Wanted
[Music]
Jedi
remind our friend here why is God under
supposed to be dead
[Music]
here we go
after all we've done
has only grown stronger
[Music]
thanks bud
part of the joke guesses
the Jedi is a threat
not now that we have this
[Music]
as long as we fight
[Music]
hope survives
[Music]
[Applause]
the hero of Star Wars Jedi Survivor
Cameron Monahan
all right
it's an incredible honor to wield this
lightsaber again
and I think I can speak for everybody at
respawn EA and lucasfilm when I say how
incredibly excited we are to show our
work on Jedi Survivor
I had the chance to play the game
recently and I can honestly say that
this is one of the best Star Wars games
of all time I'm not saying something
yeah I have no doubt that you'll feel
the same way when you play it too
and I just got to say that I am so
incredibly lucky to be a part of this
incredible project and it's really
something extraordinary so
we'll see you all in a galaxy far far
away March 17th and until then
May the force be with you
play look incredible I can't wait to
play Jedi Survivor thanks to respawn and
EA for giving us that first ever look at
the gameplay next we're proud to support
independent games here at the game
awards this next World premiere comes
from a game award-winning Studio up in
my native Canada
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
it starts in the desert
you cling to life
you find others friends
you wander the dry dirty streets of
civilization
[Music]
in the ancient Halls of the testing
state
you seek the secrets of the
ever-shifting sands
ice
you do all of these things in my dream
sleeper
I am terrified of what happens when you
awaken
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that was your first in-engine look at
Dune Awakening tonight all the major
gaming platforms are offering special
discounts and offers on TGA nominees you
can check out the game awards sale
across steam Xbox PlayStation epic store
and special offers on nominees on the
Nintendo eShop and that's not all in
celebration of TGA you can also play
free demos of many upcoming games across
steam Xbox and for the first time
PlayStation and right now we're excited
to share news about a playable demo
going live tonight on PlayStation
control
before you came the people had resigned
themselves to their fate
cowering in fear of those Hunters
but now
because of you
they might just stand a chance
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
with the news
our Indie Partners bring a whole world
of fun they spend New Life into familiar
faces keep players on their toes put
dance battles front and center challenge
us to aim higher and create Secrets
destined to be discovered all before the
eyes of a captive audience so here's a
big thanks we can't wait to see where
the fun takes you next
nice
from now through December 31st get a
free GrubHub vehicle skin in pubg Mobile
when you order 12 or more from Wendy's
through GrubHub and use code pubg mobile
go for the win go for GrubHub
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
where's your albino
come on enough procrastinating let's go
wanna come over for tea
we've got nothing else to do why don't I
tell you a story there's no such thing
as Pure Freedom in this world even the
wind cannot blow on forever those plants
have wintered Simon doesn't like the
look of this
gotcha here comes the cat The Wind Rises
[Music]
bow your head
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
impact now in the middle of its third
year and a double nominee tonight and a
sneak peek at yao yao in upcoming
character to join its growing roster
next is something truly truly special
tonight all of us together get to
experience the global announcement of
the next game from one of our industry's
most Visionary game studios
get ready please enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and pretend you
so let love
warn you
sail the Moon
[Music]
with you
by your side
close your
tires and I'll wait
and soon
I'll see your smile
in her dreams baby
don't worry
it's okay
I'll always be with you
[Applause]
hi
[Music]
[Applause]
baby
don't worry
it's okay
no one should have to suffer such loss
you know I meant it when I said I
understand how you feel if you hold on
to the sadness it'll rain down like an
anchor
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
please join me in welcoming back to the
game awards a true legend Mr hideo
Kojima
thank you
[Applause]
hockey great to see you uh well Mr
kojimo it's been three years you're on
this stage with us in 2019 where you won
best game Direction uh DS2 has been
announced uh what can you tell us how is
it going to be different than DS1
[Music]
I can't really be specific right now but
you just seen the trailer and I put a
lot of things inside so I want you guys
to talk about it and find Details in it
good luck all right uh well I know we
have some of uh the cast from the game
with us here hello great to have you
guys with us here Troy is here as well
we heard him there hello Troy
um we're so excited about this
collaboration you have with with an
amazing cast I wanted to ask you the
story of this game how is the pandemic
and what we've been through how has that
impacted your storytelling and the theme
of this game
well I had the story written before the
pandemic but after experiment
experiencing the pandemic I just rewrote
the whole thing the story from scratch
I also didn't want to predict any more
future so I rewrote it
all right Mr
I wanted to ask generally what's next
for you as a Creator I know we have our
fun podcast we do what else do you have
planned okay
well yes I'm doing the DS2 right now and
also one other title that's completely
new I'm kind of experimenting at the
moment and also other visual projects
I'm still working on so I'll hope to
reveal it soon
I said well you're always very prolific
and we love you for it hideo Kojima
everyone
[Applause]
thank you
thank you well next we have another
Global game announcement we're proud to
announce a new game for any new world
for a new AAA independent Studio
ascendant Studios a team with experience
making story driven FPS games like Dead
Space Halo and Bioshock they partnered
with EA Originals label label behind
last year's Game of the Year winner it
takes two to create a single player
magic shooter set within a new original
World here is your first glimpse
foreign
The Immortals are more than soldiers
we're the champion Protectors of Lucy
the hero of ilium fields
all you are is angry
all of AVM is crumbling apart you don't
win in everwolf
you help us win this
I'll know you're ready
[Music]
now he's an actor who recently performed
in midnight mass and Ghostbusters
Spirits Unleashed please welcome Rahul
Kohli
as an actor I'm drawn towards stories
but I think that's true of all of us
especially those who pick up a
controller narrative in games is a
slippery thing because there's no single
way to tell a story the beginning middle
and end may not even happen in that
order and for each of us there may be
different outcomes altogether but to be
truly invested in a game's story is to
step away and feel as if you've lived
another life these are the nominees for
best narrative
best narrative Hugo was always worried
that it would start all over again
nothing deserve this the golden order is
broken because
[Applause]
and the game Award for best narrative
Ghost 2
God of War Ragnarok
[Applause]
[Music]
me
there are so many people a lot of them
over there who should be on this stage
with me right now
um
so much goes into the telling of a story
in a video game from writers animators
cine artists level and Technical
designers artists
QA programmers audio music
[Music]
it's not just what's on the page
obviously our incredible cast
they elevate everything that we do put
on the page I'm just I'm honored to
accept this on their behalf I want to
thank uh Playstation Scott
permanent
I want to thank oh God our SMS I.T and
Facilities the the thing the heavy
lifting they had to do when we all had
to shift to work from home that's
incredible and they're still supporting
us now
um
I'm just uh I'm grateful to be here I'm
grateful for your support all the
nominees in this category you all have
my undying respect
I also want to thank obviously Yumi uh
Corey and our captain Eric Williams
rich and I after Corey stepped aside for
this one rich and I couldn't have asked
for a more supportive and incredible
creative partner and we're grateful for
you every single day uh oh I'm sorry I
also want to thank our families who went
from having to see us in the morning and
at night to having to see us all day
every day
that's that's a burden I wouldn't wish
for on anyone
my uh wife Suzanne my son James thank
you very much I love you and I'll see
you later
foreign
Ragnarok today is December 8th so it
just made sense to show you the first
ever game play of Tekken 8.
haradasan and the team are hard at work
on the next installment in this
legendary fighting franchise
pointed
to you
take a used also the meters there
foreign
[Applause]
now it's time to recognize more Awards
and winners here are the nominees for
best art Direction Elden ring God of War
Ragnarok Horizon forbidden West scorn
and stray
and the game award goes to
Eldon ring congratulations
here are the nominees for best VR AR
game after the fall Among Us VR bone lab
Moss Book 2 and red matter two and the
game award goes to
Moss book two congratulations
next the nominees for best Sims strategy
game Dune spice Wars Mario and rabbits
Sparks of Hope Total War Warhammer three
-point campus and Victoria three and the
game award this year goes to Mario and
Rabbids Sparks at home the Beats here I
think congratulations here are the
nominees for best community support
presented by Discord Apex Legends
Destiny 2 Final Fantasy 14. fortnite and
no man's sky and the game award goes to
Final Fantasy 14. congratulations
make sure to check out their Discord
community at the address below we have
much more game awards still to come and
right now here's a new look at
Nightingale a first person PVE open
world survival crafting game that we
first announced last year right here at
the game awards
thank you
the year is 1889.
the world as you know it
is on the brink
the magical network of portals has
collapsed
your people are cast asunder beyond the
frontiers of your reality
Realms alive with monstrous beasts
Eldritch creatures and dangers of which
you cannot conceive
you must gather your wits craft
whatsoever you require
and build a life in the Realms
uncover the secrets of ram cards
Adventure deeper into the unknown
[Applause]
[Music]
Brown Walker
your path forward is winding and full of
Terrors
save yourself
survive the Realms
and rebelled all that has been lost
[Music]
tonight in celebration of the game
awards Verizon has a special offer by an
Xbox series s from Verizon you'll get a
free controller scan the QR code below
to pick up an Xbox series s and follow
average Jonas on Instagram at average
underscore Jonas for more fun details
foreign
from tonight until the end of December
you can get an exclusive chance for 10
off of the Samsung 990 Pro SSD at
samsung.com us to enhance your gaming
experience the promo code is 990 Pro TGA
22. all right our next presenters are
absolute Legends they attended the very
first game awards where we honored them
with our first industry icon award they
founded Sierra online they brought us
Half-Life king's quest and hundreds of
other titles and this show my career in
gaming would not exist without them
their latest game their back making
games which we're excited about is
called Colossal Cave and it launches
January 19th everyone please join me in
welcoming to the game awards Ken and
Roberta Williams
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
started making games many many years ago
we knew the potential was there to
achieve almost anything even to change
the world
we're honored to be back here to present
the award for games for impact
which recognizes games that change the
way people think and feel about the
world
here are the nominees
games for impact
[Music]
swearing won't happen again I just want
to know that we can make it through this
every cycle you take your chances wake
up sleeper
it's hard not to drift into the past
[Music]
and the game award for games for impact
goes to
as dusk Falls
[Applause]
[Music]
on my head bring God Almighty let me
tell you what he said
go tell that midnight
wow um
thank you so much I had notes but
um I forgot everything so let's
improvise
the game we made together with this
amazing team was like eight years in the
making we really hoped to create you
know an experience that was unique
narrative that was intense grounded and
also communal because as dustfuls he's
multiplayer and super inclusive and
approachable
and so the story of us Los fosak
presents you know
floats characters
normal people that struggle with their
real life issues and are thrown in super
intense pressure cooker situations
and we hope that players would feel
empathy for them and in the process
would
learn a little bit about their values
like reflect on what's important for
them and so super thrilled to be here
tonight
it means that hopefully the game
resonated with some of you very happy so
thankful I wanna especially thank our
team which is an amazing team at
internites the best team I've ever
worked with
Microsoft for their amazing support and
partnership and my family Clemons Excel
I love you infinity forever
foreign
[Music]
congratulations to Interior night
Baldur's Gate 3 is the next big RPG from
larion Studios the creators of dfinity
original sin and now the team at laryn
is ready to share just when you're going
to be able to join the party
tell me why have you come here
[Music]
it's not cured ourselves of the entire
Cult of the absolute
people like you
sites in their brains
all the way here from Baldur's Gate
may just be the godsend we've been
praying for
you're the same as me you have a mind
flare tadpole in your brain let's try to
find a solution together before it's too
late
there's a gust of weave about you but
it's a near Breeze
I your only chance of survival
you want to play the hero so badly fine
let's make this interesting
we fight we die and we just hope that
when our time comes there is someone
else to take our place
[Music]
my this place is fun
foreign
[Music]
I want you to meet a friend who sees the
world
in simple terms
not just a friend
a legend
he's not the kind of man who takes
kindly to captivity
the cult captured him
I almost feel sorry for them
looks amazing I'm here with Joe MADD
legendary comic artist and CEO of
Airship Syndicate Joe tonight you have a
new title to announce right we do a few
months ago we announced that we were
partnered with digital extreme which has
made Warframe uh just a huge success
over the last 10 years and now we're
going to leverage uh their expertise on
our new game which is a character based
online action RPG set in a brand new
fantasy world and we're super excited
and uh I think there's a little bit more
you got another partner to talk about
too we do another partner has come on
board to support us and help us reach
even more players around the world and
you'll be able to play it a lot sooner
than you might think so okay well let's
take a look at the official announcement
the world premiere here we go thanks
trouble
the Gloom
it's a rival brought chaos
but we found a way to control it
path
[Music]
we Face the danger
we Control the Chaos
to reconnect our broken world
we've all bought many paths
sharpen many blades played a few tricks
crushed a few skulls
but now we fight as one
we are wayfinders
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
the time has come
[Music]
finally we're free
we're just growing really of each
other's conversations lend me your
strength
don't hold this against me
foreign
[Music]
Chen from that game company creators of
Journey and sky and singer songwriter
Aurora welcome to the game awards and
we're right after the show tonight you
are going to be performing a virtual and
free concert in sky is that right yes
and I'm so excited I'm sorry about my
voice it's so [ __ ] up it's saying
karaoke last night
I mean yes
but tonight it will be very good
obviously yes so tell us this is an
amazing collaboration uh working with
Genova and the team why did you want to
do this
um I'm so excited about it mostly
because all of the people that are
working on Sky children of flight and
Genova it's just the best kind of people
and it feels like this this project is
so full of love and and light and
understandment
um of The Outsiders in the world and
finding a way to make us feel home and
connected it's very it's just pure yeah
I got to experience it last week and it
really is very moving I think it's kind
of the future where virtual concerts
should go Genova you've always built
games about connecting people you know
relationships what I wouldn't Peg you as
someone that would go into the virtual
concert space but this is very special
tell us why did you want to do this yeah
I mean historically we always want to
push the boundary of how a game can make
you feel and with our game Journey we
connect two people but with sky and now
the upcoming answered we want to try to
see connect thousands of people together
emotionally and this is just something
that I've never experienced and to be
honest like I just played it with 4 000
people this week and I don't know what
to say but so maybe we can just look at
a trailer and hopefully that will help
to explain amazing let's check it out
thanks guys
from flow flower journey to Sky that
game company continued to push the
boundary of video games emotional
potential
can video game create a genuine human
connection and bring players across the
world closer like a concert
in a real life concert you feel the
collective energy of thousands of
beautiful souls around you you connect
with the artist and their message at a
personal level
s in any video games
and after 18 months of experimentation
and development we feel it now
we made this concert completely free so
you can experience this amazing journey
with your friends and loved ones you can
download on any of these platforms and
take less than a minute from boot to
concert join us for this groundbreaking
moment shared by millions of players
worldwide
[Music]
check that out it's really really
special all right this year we partnered
with GrubHub to get your food delivered
for the game awards when you order from
Wendy's on GrubHub using the code pubg
mobile you'll receive a free vehicle
wrap on orders of 12 or more through the
end of December players will also be
able to participate in pubg Mobile and
complete other challenges terms and
conditions apply
uh
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I have returned to hell
for you
wow Diablo 4 and Halsey are just getting
started on their collaboration leading
up to the launch more from Diablo and
Halsey next year but wasn't that
incredible thank you so much Halsey all
right now we'd like to recognize some
other winners tonight in the category of
best sports racing game the nominees are
f-122 FIFA 23 NBA 2K 23 Gran Turismo 7
and Ali Ali world and the game award
goes to
Gran Turismo 7. congratulations
here are your nominees for best
multiplayer game Call of Duty Modern
Warfare 2.
multiverses OverWatch 2 Splatoon 3 and
TMNT Shredder's revenge
and the game award goes to
Splatoon three
all right now the nominees for best
audio design Cod Modern Warfare 2 Alden
ring God of War Ragnarok Gran Turismo 7
Horizon forbidden West
and this game award goes to
God of War Ragnarok
having a pretty good night
here are the nominees for content
creator of the Year Carl Jacobs
Ludwig
Rebellion
no brew and QT Cinderella
and the game award goes to
Ludwig congratulations man
here are the nominees for most
anticipated game
Final Fantasy 16.
Hogwarts Legacy
Resident Evil 4.
Starfield
and The Legend of Zelda tears of the
Kingdom
maybe a fan favorite but and the game
award goes to
The Legend of Zelda tears of the Kingdom
congratulations to all our winners so
far and now it's time for another world
premiere
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
pursue a Sinister threat in the Untamed
Wilds of Los Angeles and yes even the
Hollywood Sign isn't spared and now
please welcome the cast of The Last of
Us show coming to HBO on January 15th
that's right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just just real quick I I know that I
told you guys this backstage but just in
front of everybody else I want to let
you know
we've seen the show and
we just love you as Joe and Ellie thank
you thank you big fans big fans so you
know we are big fans of you two as well
as Joel and Ellie
um so should we do this all together
just like Joel and Ellie's just one and
all let's do it
yeah okay
okay
we're here to present the award for best
action game nailed it many games have
action and these are the ones
this kicks ass
here
the production game
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
parties dude
all right
Tina
and the game award for the best action
games
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right this is pretty awesome
um on behalf of the development teams at
Platinum Games
and Nintendo that worked tirelessly on
bringing Bayonetta to life for the third
time thank you so very much it's about
noon back in Japan tomorrow and I'm sure
they're watching right now so this is
for you folks congratulations
I think you all know this but no one
does
action games and over-the-top action
games like Platinum Games and as you saw
they're already hard at work on their
next project so they asked me to say a
few words on their behalf
with our long history of creating action
games it's a huge honor to be awarded
Beck's action game for Bayonetta three
we're also delighted to have been able
to reveal a brand new title for the game
awards today we'd like to thank everyone
who helped us bring the game to life and
of course the fans of the series with
the characters just as important as the
many players as the many to the many
players is gameplay we hope you'll keep
your eyes peeled for ceresas next
stories
from everyone at Platinum games thank
you very much thank you
[Music]
congratulations to PG and Nintendo and
next we have a trio of exciting new game
announcements first let's head to Japan
for a special announcement
s
okay
foreign
foreign
what our world was before
before the sundering
[Music]
before the war
before the darkness
do you remember
[Music]
you will
[Music]
on this side
[Music]
your future needs you
[Applause]
[Music]
but I'm never right
away
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this ain't worth
[Applause]
coming up Animal from the Muppets drops
by and Keegan Michael Key shares a new
look at the Super Mario Brothers movie
and still to come the award for best
game Direction stick around
[Music]
more
[Applause]
don't go
back
[Music]
Company of Heroes 3 console edition
coming in 2023
there is no Victory to be had here
there is only survival
the
strength of your resolve is the only
thing that will grant you another day
devours everything
[Music]
I have found no meaning
when the end comes for you
not yield
towards the season of teaching when all
through the land not at all guide was
stirring not even
whether the beans have been naughty or
nice there were presents on offer in the
snow and the ice in the store for all a
ski costume for free a new snippy dive
slide to tackle with Glee those
resourceful enough to complete gift grab
May stumble forth as a nutcracker thus
looking fan foot is the season for fun
and frolics for all even SpongeBob has
answered the call so this holiday season
celebrating style curl up by the fire
and play fall guys for a while
that looks absolutely so amazing let's
let's yes I like the energy as you can
see I'm now joined by animal from the
upcoming Muppets Mayhem uh say hi animal
uh
yeah
we are at the game awards I love this
enthusiasm animal so I have to ask what
do you want to play do you have a
certain game or uh Thomas
I didn't imagine you being a soulsborne
player
do you have a favorite boss in Elder
ring
millennia
yeah
you're still thinking about it she's so
pretty tough in the game uh well now
that I know you're such a big game fan
have you ever thought about kind of
appearing in your own game or having an
animal game oh yeah yeah box
[Laughter]
yeah I I guess you could we'll talk to
hideo at the after party see what we can
make happen uh but all right what if
that didn't work out and so you had to
make your own game what would you call
it ah animal
Crossing
I think that one's taken the Nintendo
lawyers might have some issues with that
but anyways animal it's great to have
you here at the game awards should we
maybe give out an award now what do you
think about that oh yeah music music
okay animal has spoken let's check out
the nominees for best score and music
heads
best score and music
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay animal okay and the game Award for
best score and music goes to
God of War Ragnarok
congratulations
wow animal whoa buddy my favorite
drummer I don't believe it
I literally don't believe it uh no thank
you so much everybody
um but I really got to give a shout out
to everybody at Santa Monica Studio
Corey
when you told me this story eight years
ago
uh I was moved to tears then and it's
been a part of my life ever since uh and
Eric Williams uh you really brought this
out of me man uh thank you so much all
the musicians Ivor and Hosier who's up
here tonight uh all the ethnic um fiddle
players and and hardinger Fiddle and
nickel harp all these wonderful
um musicians from around the world also
lent their uh their beautiful uh
performances but I just also want to say
I I I've learned the power of Simplicity
and Kratos is a man of few words and I
wanted to write him just a few notes and
I got to write
[Music]
and if I only wrote that I I I I feel
like the story would sort of be there so
I got to write a lot more thank you so
much everybody this means the world to
me thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations bear and now it's time
for an exclusive reveal of a brand new
action RPG developed by the creators of
life is strange don't nod and published
by Focus entertainment
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you must say some strange things
[Music]
we had our share yes but I've never seen
a gross myself
but they are real
right
[Music]
so what you truck and kill him is that
it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it takes a brave man to walk these Wilds
alone
[Music]
I'm not alone
a bone Walker
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
ERS of mankind against the horrors that
dwell in the darkness
[Music]
while we draw breath we stand
while we stand we fight
we
fight
we
are the Angels of death we are the blade
drawn against the Endless Night
nothing
Will Survive our Wrath
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
that was a look at meet your makers sign
up for the upcoming beta the game
launches April 4th 2023. all week twitch
is celebrating what games week
recognizing all the games from gaming
history that never got their proper due
like EA's overblood which was the most
played game this week as a game from
1997. which game Saw the biggest
increase in viewership over the week
according to a twitch Twitter poll the
winner was Katamari all right we've got
much more game awards ahead more World
premieres including an update on Final
Fantasy 16 and of course the game of the
year presented by last year's winner
Joseph Ferris who knows what she's going
to say hopefully it's short all right
we'll be right back
here's to colorful competition here's to
inking Turf together here's to every
friend every rival every splat
Here's to You Splatoon 3 community
[Applause]
you Richard scum
do you have any idea what black polish
moving get it
dodging
passing
protecting the ball carrier and crushing
the hell out of your opponents oh I know
luck could have been with us but that's
not an excuse
blood bowl is a demanding sport your
opponents want your heads and even their
fans will murder you if they have the
jobs finish your drinks pull yourself
together get out there and win me this
man
[Applause]
we are at War
and she's in danger you will find her
and bring her to me
the hands after her
to her Defender at all costs
who are you you
know
a legend cannot be killed can it
welcome back to the game awards coming
to the stage now
[Music]
[Applause]
careful with the fur I'm a little
sensitive thank you what's up game
awards crashes in the building let's go
get ready for an epic reveal in three
two
one
zero
negative one
negative two guys
where's my crew
hold on a second
what happened we were supposed to meet
up here and steal all the bumper fruit
from the game awards which I'm now
realizing was a fruitless plan
oh excuse me are you guys on mute oh I
get it the old silent treatment that's
fine
more Wampa for me wherever it is
whatever
roll the trailer grandma
I'm a real king
[Applause]
presence
foreign
real
King
[Applause]
now please welcome two outstanding
content creators and streamers here are
foosli and Valkyrie
bikinis to rapidly evolve every year if
there's one category that seems to
advance the fastest and furthest its
Innovation and accessibility each year
designers impress and Inspire Us by
discovering new and thoughtful ways to
enable an even larger audience to play
their games through determined
consideration for those who are often
marginalized here are the Game Awards
nominees for innovation in accessibility
Innovation and accessibility it's a
single player and multiplayer experience
we want to draw in people who weren't
necessarily Gamers I might be able to
get up there if you help me
when you are unsure of the way forward
open this book for guidance that Suite
of features enables gameplay by players
who are blind in their low vision
[Music]
and the game award for Innovation and
accessibility goes to
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you everyone we are absolutely
humbled and grateful to everyone who's
helped us in this journey along the way
because playing games is what's
important for the players it's you all
you who play the games that are really
the ones that deserve this award
everyone who was on the team at SMS we
are truly honored to be with you thank
you so much Eric and Yumi for supporting
us John and Jason for being there while
we were trying to make these
accessibility features happen Katie Sam
and Zach my closest cohorts when we were
trying to make these features and all of
our team in the QA and accessibility
research teams the UI ux team and
everyone who made it possible I can't
thank you enough and I think that the
players themselves are the ones that are
going to benefit the most this is a race
that no matter who wins the player is
the real winner so let's go out there
and make all games have no limits thank
you
foreign
[Applause]
Radiance We Trust
Shield our souls with Grace our hearts
with hope
and guide our path a tunnel
internal case for what lies beyond your
luster where wickedness dwells and the
Shadows rain the arms of your gold
together
maybe Vanquish the darkness
in light
we walk
foreign
[Applause]
and now from 505 games a new organized
crime game Crime Boss Rocky City please
welcome Kirby Joe Grubb Damian Wade and
the boss himself Michael Mr Michael
Madsen
together
game awards we are here to slide us we
are here to set a slightly different
tone for the trailer you're about to
watch
you see this trailer here well
a little different than the rest of
these trailers you're seeing tonight
this one's a little bit dangerous
so the boss wanted to come out here you
know make sure you don't hurt yourself
sometime during the next 60 Seconds
wow
what a crowd
my God what a night wow
wow um
listen I uh
I've had some wild times uh
I've been involved in some crazy things
in my life
um
I even made a picture with Mr Al Pacino
uh
Donnie Brasco if you haven't seen it you
should look it up God damn it so
look it up
anyway I have to say being the Crime
Boss of Rocket City
now that's a lot of fun
and uh we've got an amazing cast with us
these two handsome guys with me
and uh anyway
enjoy the debut trailer for Crime Boss
Rock case City coming March 28th 2023 so
let's roll it
so you wanna be a criminal game
that's right Chuck Norris all right and
now we are happy to announce more
winners here at the game awards based on
votes from our jury and fans around the
world here are the nominees for best
role-playing game Elden ring live alive
alive Pokemon Legends Arceus triangle
strategy Xenoblade Chronicles 3 and the
game award goes to Eldon ring
congratulations to from Bandai Namco
here are the nominees for players voice
are 100
fan voted category you guys were very
busy voting the past few days nominee
Sonic Frontiers Kenshin impact Eldon
ring God of War Ragnarok and stray and
once we took out all the bot boats the
game award goes to
Kenshin impact
here are the nominees for best
independent game Cult of the Lamb neon
white sifu stray
tunic and the game award goes to stray
congratulations a double winner tonight
here are the nominees for best action
adventure game a plague tale Requiem God
of War Ragnarok Horizon forbidden West
stray and tunic and the game award goes
to
God of War Ragnarok
here are the nominees for best ongoing
game Apex Legends Destiny 2 Final
Fantasy 14 fortnite and gentian impact
and the game award goes to Final Fantasy
14 the second time tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
I'm coming
what the hell is this place
up next Reggie is in the building and
his body is ready plus naoki Yoshida
takes the stage and the game awards
Orchestra honors the nominees for Game
of the Year
hey I'm Ben Bruno from second dinner the
developers of Marvel snap and we are so
excited about our new collaboration with
Martin Garrix and Jake on this
incredible new music video that explores
love throughout the Multiverse here's a
clip of hero
[Music]
hello hello hello hello
we have another people in here right now
how are you feeling what's up Kenzie I
see you all here what up what up what up
my name is Michael Reynolds and I am the
fierce Diva where have you been so to me
what it means is just being very
authentically myself
and apologetically me
my mental health is very important to me
for several reasons constantly thought
that I was lesser than my peers I just
could never Focus but going through that
mental health Journey with my therapist
who I Adore we learned that I had add it
gave me a whole new perspective on my
life and gave me a lot of answers that I
didn't even know that I was seeking girl
I'm dead I'm dead there ain't no way I'm
surviving this [ __ ] oh
it hurts honey it hurts I knew that I
wanted to help Usher that experience for
folks that really needed it thank you
for the love per usual the mess per
usual if I am inspiring other people to
be authentic if I'm inspiring people to
seek mental health then I definitely
feel good about that
he drops by every December just like
Santa give it up for Reggie
[Applause]
after
[Applause]
hey
[Applause]
so this year I'm here to present the
best game Direction category
and it's a particularly exciting award
especially in our industry
games are constantly pushing the
boundaries of creativity
Innovation and artistry
and to be nominated
you need to have created an experience
that is incredibly special to the
players
to the teams represented Behind these
titles you have my utmost respect
here are the nominees for the best game
Direction
best game Direction
[Music]
the land is dying I'm running out of
time
in five b take one he shot twenty
thousand girls you picked you
[Music]
and the game Award for best game
Direction goes to
Eldon ring
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
ERS are you know the biggest game that
we have ever worked on
um so we have worked with uh several
code electors including Mr tanimura and
Mr ishizaki
um without their support
um it's it will be almost impossible to
you know finish working on this project
um so we really want to share the this
great joy of this evening's Award with
them
[Applause]
thank you
so once again thank you so much for your
support
[Music]
how many times you willing to get burned
before you stop trusting someone
foreign
how many times you gotta take a bullet
for these [ __ ] in the name of
empty promises
politicians military Runners
intelligence operatives all the Run fish
in one [ __ ] Barrel this dog town
tell me you've got a plan not a plan
a man
there's anyone we can trust now it's him
Solomon real f.i.a
so what do we do now
dog town running to the grounds what
we'll do it's a simple choice
them for us
peace comes at a price someone's always
got to pay
game awards what's up get yourself a
hand I just want to let you know how
excited I am to play nusa agent Solomon
Reed in cyberpunk 2077 Phantom Liberty
can't wait for you guys to meet Reed
when Phantom Liberty releases in 2023
see you in 19
. thanks Idris tonight we are thrilled
to share with you another Global game
announcement this comes from one of the
most decorated developers in the world
who consistently pushes this medium
forward for each of its releases this
studio has been nominated multiple times
for Game of the Year here at this very
show and I am beyond grateful that they
have chosen the game awards as the place
for This Global announcement
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
the 2022 game of the year right here on
the game awards
there was an outbreak
they killed everyone
I container
these are accidents they're all
connected
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
that was a look at Wild Hearts coming
from Koi Tecmo and EA Originals next
year and now we welcome one of the
busiest men in gaming known finally by
his fans as Yoshi P both the producer
and director of the successful online
role-playing game Final Fantasy 14
winner of two game awards tonight and
producer of the highly anticipated new
entry and the acclaimed Final Fantasy
franchise Final Fantasy XV please join
me in welcoming for the first time to
TGA Mr naoki Yoshida
foreign
on behalf of the Final Fantasy 16 team
I'm honored to be here to present you
with tonight
final World premiere
to all our fans
thank you for keeping faith in us
happy I hope you enjoy our latest
trailer Revenge
[Applause]
take Joshua and get to safety
I've got to hold the enemy here while
you make you escape
your highness
run
run oh God
[Music]
revenge is a weapon
foreign
I sometimes wonder if I am controlling
it or if it's controlling me
foreign
so cool
what do we do the usual
so I've waited for this chance
you're dying today
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
please welcome the director of hazelite
studios and last year's Game of the Year
winner for it takes two here's Joseph
Ferris
yeah really nice being on stage again
actually it feels really good I know I
know a lot of people are nervous but
don't be I'm gonna be super cool and
short so
uh let's see now yeah I remember
recently uh last year winning game of
the year it's a fantastic feeling so
obviously as a nominee you should be
very happy and very proud but trust me
you do want to win because it's a great
feeling
but however you do actually win
something the game modes are super cool
because you know this beautiful
Orchestra when they play the music from
your game I mean I was sitting over
there and trust me the hair all hair or
my body was all over the place no uh
Goosebump I mean it's really awesome so
uh please give a big Applause to the
beautiful Orchestra and conducted by
long dog
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
all right
Game of the Year winner is
Elder ring
[Applause]
foreign thank you so much
[Applause]
foreign
team members everybody at France
software our partner Banda and Amco all
collaborators and last night but at
least Mr Jordan Martin who created the
great Mythos for this game
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
this game so as a director I'm really
relieved
and this might not be the you know light
thing to say at the you know the only
location of the
um receiving the goatee award but I have
made up my mind to create even more
interesting games than this one
[Applause]
foreign foreign
we still have
several more things we want to do
um so this getting this goatee award
really really encourage us
so step
um
foreign
[Music]
um and we create the games we want to
create and do our best because of you
um thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
you know real quick I want to thank
everybody and say that I think I want to
nominate this award to my reformed
Orthodox Rabbi Bill Clinton thank you
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
all right well the vet believed it
congratulations this has been such a
special night and I can't believe that
next year 2023 marks the 10th Annual
game awards so we are lucky to do this
every year we want to thank all the
industry for their support and of course
all of you around the world viewers of
the show tonight I do have one last
special announcement from us to
celebrate our 10th year the game awards
is thrilled to be partnering with the LA
Phil for a very special evening of video
game Music performed live at the world
famous Hollywood Bowl next year on June
25th 2023 we will be celebrating the
past decade of video game music and
looking ahead to its future you'll be
hearing much more about this historic
collaboration early next year until then
thank you so much have a safe and happy
holiday season and we'll see you in
2023. good night everybody
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]